i've got breaking news shocking news no
i'm not talking about the senate races
in georgia
i don't really care about that news
anymore it's you know it's going to be
what it's going to be
no i've got a much more shocking news
from nbc
trans women retain athletic edge
after a year of hormone therapy study
fines a new study suggests
transgender women also known as men
maintain an athletic advantage over
their cisgender peers
also known as women even after a year on
hormone therapy oh my goodness
you're kidding me wow it would appear
that the
genius experts with many many years of
medical training
research training mds and phds they have
finally
concluded a study that shows what
people with even a modicum of common
sense have always known to be true
namely that men are physically stronger
than women
can you imagine we have all seen
in recent years as the gender ideology
craze
has swept through schools and swept
through the culture and swept through
sports
there will be some women's track race
and you'll have these two
little 90 pound girls and they're
running the drag race and then you get
some one
some like 140 pound 160 pound dude
who has long hair and who is pretending
to be a woman
and wouldn't you know he always wins the
track race
and and then we all have to pretend like
well no maybe
he was on hormone therapy and you know i
don't know he had some kind of plastic
surgery so
maybe it's a fair fight it's obviously
not a fair fight
if you permit men in dresses
to play in women's sports then there's
no such thing as women's sports
i'm not i don't exactly watch the wnba
okay i'm not like i don't even watch the
regular nba
so i the sports thing does not really
bother me from an entertainment
perspective
but it is deeply unfair isn't it i mean
the whole point of title ix
was that women are allowed to have their
own sports leagues and then gender
ideology comes in and says no you don't
and it's kind of funny because title ix
was at the time considered a very
liberal progressive movement
and then it created these women's sports
teams and leagues and
allowed women to get scholarships and
allowed women to get awards and
have the glory of playing in games and
then
another left-wing movement a far more
left-wing movement comes in and says
actually women
no you don't get you don't get those
sports leagues
this actually ties back into what we
were talking about between the
economics obsessed people on the right
you know just the kind of
mitt romney ben sasse technic rat types
and the cultural fighters
guys like donald trump or josh hawley or
ted cruz
or the guys who actually lean into those
questions
the economics obsessed right wing the
basically
liberal establishmentarian right wing
they don't want to talk about this
they what they're going to say is oh
come on how many
people are really confused about their
sex it's obviously a very
sad condition if a guy thinks he's a
girl and so let's just let him look
let's just indulge that delusion let him
compete in the
in the women's track race and he's
obviously going to beat the girls and
he's going to take their scholarships
and he's going to take their awards but
come on let's be it would be nice to him
and frankly i just don't want to deal
with it because i'm over here busy
trying to lower taxes
and allow multinational corporations to
expand and try to open our borders to
flood the country with
illegal aliens and then give amnesty to
them later so come on i'm trying to
pursue all these really important
conservative things
why should i care if
if boys are going into the girls
changing room why should i care
about that's such a minor issue it's not
a minor issue
and and by the way if this were a minor
issue i agree that
the sexual confusion affects a very
small number of people although it is
spreading like a social contagion the
number of of
uh gen zers people below them you know
younger than the millennials who are
confused about their sex and gender has
skyrocketed in recent years so it
it there's both a psychological element
but it also spread socially
uh to to varying degrees but i agree it
affects a small number of people except
not really if one boy
takes away a scholarship from one girl
that is a political problem
by beating her at girl sports if one
guy can go into the little girl's
changing room
that is a political problem even if it
doesn't happen that often
that's a big political problem if
this issue this the gender ideology
issue were really
some minor issue then why is the left
spending so much time and so
much money and so much energy
pushing for it and when they say who
cares well
the left cares maybe they care for a
reason
don't forget the whole this whole
bathroom controversy
can men go into the ladies room this
began
because the left in charlotte north
carolina
decided to allow to pass a bill
to allow men to go into the girls room
they were the aggressors in that culture
war when we hear from the
you know the the squishy republican
types oh give up the culture wars
the conservatives are by definition not
the aggressors in the culture wars
right we're trying to conserve things
we're trying to conserve an old standard
the
obviously the aggressors in the culture
wars are the radicals who are trying to
overthrow those standards and
implement new ones we've got we should
talk about this so much more than we
talk about
most economic issues if those squishy
republicans
would put one 100th of the energy
into keeping men out of girls track
meets and men out of the girls changing
room as they put into
trying to keep the stimulus bill from uh
at 600
rather than expanding to 2 000 if they
put just one iota
of that effort we would hold the culture
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
[Music]
[Music]